Macht dieses knusprige Fingerfood unbedingt nach!
Aber erstmal will ich einen Tik Tok Hack testen.
Und dafür gebe ich Petersilie einfach in meine Reibe
und ziehe da die Stängel unten durch.
Das Ergebnis gefällt mir richtig gut, denn guckt mal:
Das alles ist liegen geblieben!
Die Petersilie hacke ich jetzt fein und gebe sie zusammen mit Fetakäse
und Gouda in eine Schüssel.
Das ist die leckere Füllung und als nächstes in eine Dose
Ei, Milch und Öl miteinander verrühren.
Ich mach's so, dass ich ganz einfach schüttel und fertig ist das Ganze!
Dreieckige Yufkablätter jetzt mit der Mischung bepinseln
und die Füllung ganz oben an den Rand geben.
Rollt das Ganze dann auf,
ich hab ungefähr 22 Röllchen rausbekommen.
Und gebt die fertigen Röllchen dann nochmal in die Eier-Milch Mischung
und tunkt sie anschließend in ordentlich Paniermehl.
Das Coole ist, dass die jetzt nicht frittiert werden,
sondern dass wir sie im Backofen bei 200° C Ober- und Unterhitze
für ca. 22min backen.